es wird gebacken ja und was wird
gebacken software cookies lukas meine
ganze haare zerstört das finde ich kein
freund mehr im internet ist wirklich
sehr sehr traurig ja das letzte mal
gebacken habe ich habe 1999 krass als
ich geboren wurde ich habe da habe ich
erst einmal selber gebacken und zwei
lillifee muffins ich hab noch nie und
steht heute auf jeden fall software
cookies also dieses amt cookies dafür
haben wir hier weil wir haben frische
bio eier wir haben backpulver wir haben
butter am weizen zucker salz schoko
tröpfchen und dem rezept steht ein jahr
dran aber wir sind keine chemie kurs von
daher dass man einfach auch so wichtig
wie das glück nicht sein also
überspringen wir das ganze ich glaube
wir brauchen auch keine backpulver oder
ist das natron
wir fangen jetzt auf jeden fall mit dem
ersten schritt an und zwar müssen wir in
butter und zucker mit dem handmixer wir
haben keinen max
hast du eine waage mit den 400 familien
schätzen grob keine ahnung butter und
zucker mit dem handmixer drei minuten
schaumig rühren dass sie seine kost
schlüssel in der wohnung vergessen wenn
ihr zu viel gesoffen weil man bei
paragon software group ist schon eklig
dass also batzen butter rein konnten
aber ich finde butter satisfied
250 gramm zum besten gefallen das sind
500 das ist in etwa die hälfte
davon gar noch mehr
doch so zwicker würde ich sagen
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen oder
ich kenne die hessen ich bin auf diät
[Gelächter]
ja gut dass wir so lange dauern
da bist du eh kraftfutter und halbmond
junger ist ein oder mal ein politiker
also wir haben jetzt hier gar nichts
neues und bisher mehr oder weniger
schaumig geschlagen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir gedacht haben weil
im rezept steht das erst jetzt drei
einreihen müssen dass wir jetzt einfach
schon ein bisschen vorher rein machen so
dass ein bisschen cremiger wird
da jetzt die schale bei der renault
kangoo als media alvermann vorhand
das gute proteine wir machen das genau
nach rezept wir haben schon geändert
räumte was auch immer das alter es
funktioniert nicht so wie es die alles
leben bleibt das ist doch völlig aus
sie sollen das sind keine kekse werden
egal
ich höre besser und wirksamer bucht uns
auf main.de
nicht verzagen nun gar fragen
das war dann wohl probier bist der profi
bist nicht geisteskrank lecker
das schränke den pico egal wie
freundlich richtig in einer separaten
schlüssel mail natron und salz mischen
und anschließend zur butter mischung
geben und mit einem löffel unter rühren
bis gerade ein zeigt so ein teig
entsteht weißt du was unter rühren ist
ich unter rühren und du machst den rest
jetzt weiß ich was unter rühren ist so
ein bisschen nur zu viel oder zu wenig
ich würde sagen wir machen einfach ein
bisschen ja so stop
di luca der hat nicht geisteskrank
schlimm denn so darf der teig der
richter ist gut mal
klappt es trotz gleich das nächste
geisteskrank schilder und jetzt leicht
unter rühren dafür brauchen wir aber
noch einen schneebesen
entscheiden wir uns für den ich glaube
der hat mehr arbeit geleistet luca und
jetzt nach und nach eingeben eingeben
freilegen reinlegen gleicht doch das
team münster sind genauso
wäre mir sieben kilo die da rein nutzen
wie lange sollen wir denn machen
währenddessen paar fragen beantworten
also die uns die community gestellt hat
fritz möchte gerne wissen warum ist luca
so viel hübscher als sandra das ist
schon mal erst mal eine fake news
deswegen kann ich die frage nicht
beantworten michelle hat ihren kommentar
geschrieben hat gesagt hey wir 90 bin
die schwester von sandra ich habe
richtig gern den podcast sicher ist der
coole report
ist ein kommentare unter den videos
eingeblendet tritt hier geschrieben ich
hatte letzte nacht was mit sandra und
richtig heftig küssend geschrieben was
sagst du dazu und wieder ist der brauch
ich weiß
jetzt schon kommt
das
ist keine geduld fassen
kein mensch braucht natron hashtag nein
so nah
trondheim muss aber natron könnte auch
ein neuer
park einfach reinkommen
wenn ich das jetzt mal mischverhältnisse
ausrechne peter einer die zu viel
schokolade
wir wissen aber alle dass andere nicht
rechnen kann von daher ist darauf
wiederum komplett egal was sie wirken
passgenau der ofen backofen sommer
genutzt so eine eiskugel ding ein
eiskugel behälter wo man nicht eiskugeln
raus kam hat was nicht wo mein gott sich
auf den eisdiele alter ja
drücken stand er nicht oder
willst du vielleicht auch weil löffel im
mund ich auch nicht mal haben beteiligen
ich glaub du kannst ihn richtig gut und
das alles ohne draht von denn ja nein
wir noch ein paar fragen beantworten
hier schon geschrieben sondern bitte hör
mir auf die ärmsten schreiben
ziemlich abstoßend
wirklich
fertig gehabt das ist mein backofen
abschieben erstmal noch einmal ich kann
er ist warum einfach ist durch
okay das heißt wir müssen jetzt zwölf
minuten warten bis sie fertig sind
wollen wir der zwischenzeit einfach weg
[Musik]
die texte sind fertig leute ich doch die
ware jetzt leider ein bisschen zu
langsam gelaufen und haben sie jetzt
richtig mitbekommen
[Musik]
was machen keine stabile übrigens erst
mal
hinzuschauen was denn hier passiert ist
das sieht aus wie pizza
außerdem gefälschte pizza aber nicht wie
cookies er hier hätten wir mal einfach
den zeit gegessen ja
die sind noch so richtig angebrannt hier
am rand aber die konsistenz eigentlich
will ich
einfach versprach ich werde wir haben
einfach golfsport in dünn gebaut sondern
probieren jetzt unsere selbst gebackenen
subway software cookies
[Musik]
vollidiot also es ist es schmeckt jetzt
nicht schlecht schmecken tut echt gut
ich dachte das geht in die höhe hier die
breite ist genauso wie ich deswegen
gesagt doch man musste nicht aus beiden
müssen so groß bleiben als battle damit
auseinander gehen ich glaube das ist es
liegt am natron
e-tron schmeckt ok zieht aber
tatsächlich aus wie ein schwamm wir
schenken mir ist auf jeden fall unseren
freunden ich hoffe die freuen sich ein
bisschen mehr als wir wenn euch dieses
video gefallen hat von sandra dassler
gerne einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video hinten ein und klickt auf die
märkte weiter - nichts zu verpassen für
sie eure handys welt also wirklich
lecker
ich bin übrigens ellis welt not hatte
ein verbot